innate
beautiful weather over the weekend
unbelievable it had a near record high
yesterday which and then by the end of
the week we're going to see temperatures
in the low 50s when lows are on freezing
yes okay so check it out i'm ready
to bring it up there's enough light for
our camera way down to the southeast on
top of black mountain to switch from
black and white over to color and you
can even see the outdoor of resorts
world with the giant video screen
viewable from henderson high clouds
overhead it's still going to keep us on
the warm side so we mentioned 49 degrees
the official temperature out at mccarran
neighborhoods check it out though
you got the mid 40s out at the air force
base and at sunrise mountain so sweaters
jackets moms dads kids make sure you
bundle up a little bit i mean it's not
parker weather but it is certainly
chilly by the ride home you should be
just fine upper 40s also for a
mountain's edge though and around rhodes
ranch seven hills and anthem you're in
the low 50s
summerlin actually the warm spot right
now that's a little unusual take away 10
42 for kyle canyon where there may be
some light snow showers nothing
measurable and certainly not enough to
get the lee canyon ski area going now to
nevada and beyond we are really all over
the place got the teens and ely that's
not unusual for this time of year
at about 10 cedar city also upper 20s
again for this time of year that's about
right kinguin has jumped up to the mid
40s matching over the hump and prep with
a 45 and really rare for beatty to be
warmer than death valley it is awfully
chilly out in death valley right now at
49 34 for tonopah 32 up in reno so
taking you hour by hour we're at 49
right now we'll at least be back to 50
with increasing clouds throughout the
day today should be the low 60s at
lunchtime we're going for the afternoon
high of 68 after yesterday's 75
so our current temperatures low so far
but we're still talking about nearly 10
degrees above normal
that's going to change big time later on
in the week we'll get to the eight day
forecast in just a second so we
mentioned a slight chance for passing
showers overnight tonight into tomorrow
nothing accumulating maybe just enough
to mess up your windshield we call that
kind of dirt rain much better chances
for rain on thursday but even more than
that very windy thursday and that's
going to usher in those much cooler
temperatures for the weekend right now
for your family and friends snow showers
in the higher elevations of the pacific
northwest stronger showers along the
ohio valley heading on up into new
england states still single digits now
and that has extended to minnesota 28
for kc 34 for oklahoma near 80 right now
in miami your 8 day forecast will drop
you to 62 after the 68 for today down to
62 tomorrow then a little bump up back
to 64 wednesday ahead of the huge
changes we're talking about a lot of
rain accumulating very windy and only
the low 50s for daytime highs friday and
saturday morning lows around the
freezing mark we may get some freeze
advisories from the national weather
service we'll keep you posted